est ce que vous imaginez une seule
seconde
le jeu vidéo service du vivant j'entends
déjà derrière ça me plaît pas souvent
associé à de la violence au repli sur
soi même à l'isolément et même à de la
stupidité
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter mon
parcours vous raconter comment j'ai
évolué dans le monde du jeu vidéo et
vous ferez votre propre avis sur la
question
j'ai grandi dans une famille de trois
enfants avec de grand frère aîné de sept
ans et 11 ans de plus que moi et à la
maison mes parents vous pouvez pas
vraiment s'occuper de moi passent ils
travailler beaucoup
donc c'est surtout mes frères qui
s'occupait de moi et leur passe-temps
préféré c'était les jeux vidéo
alors je passais mon temps à les
regarder jouer à des jeux de combat eux
ils étaient champions sur le jeu tekken
mémoire ce qui m'a vraiment fait mais
les jeux de combat
c'était le jeu soulcalibur sorti sur
dreamcast en 1998 et j'avais 7 ans c'est
un jeu de combat donc pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas c'est un jeu qui se joue
en un contre un chaque joueur choisit un
personnage et le but c'est de battre
l'autre jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
vie moi ce qui me fascine et sur ces
jeux là c'était pas tant battre l'autre
c'était vraiment ses personnages
féminins dans ses personnages féminins
je voyais de la force de la
détermination des personnages beau
gracieux et ça nous changeait des
clichés de ce qu'on pouvait voir à
l'époque je vous rappelle par exemple
mario wii une princesse à sauver une
princesse en détresse à sauver tout le
temps dans les jeux vidéos de l'époque
c'était cette image là qu on renvoyait
des filles et moi je me retrouvais pas
dans ses fils à moi je veux y est je
voulais des guerrières des femmes qui
savent se battre des femmes badass comme
on dit et donc voilà sans ses
personnages féminins que je me
retrouvais que je voulais me retrouver
plus tard que je prenais comme modèle et
j'avais envie de leur ressembler donc
souvent je prenais des personnages
asiatiques
parce que c'était plus facile pour la
petite fille que j'étais de projeter
vers l est donc j'ai développé une très
forte loyauté parce que j'avais envie de
d'être forte avec ses personnages que
j'aimais tant je m'entraînais dur avec
elle et je battais même mes frais avec
elle à sept ans déjà et c'était pas très
content je me rappelle bien y avait des
cris de rage à la maison je vous passe
tout ça mais c'était un moment
formidable que je passe avec mes grands
frères grâce au jeu de combat et grâce à
ses personnages qui monte en fait mais
ces jeux là et en voyant que j'étais
super passionnée par tout ça et que
j'avais envie de rencontrer d'autres
joueurs qui mes frères parce que bon
c'était un peu chiant d'entendre vous
fait general et tout le temps parce que
je gagnais et j'avais envie de
rencontrer d'autres joueurs qui pouvait
m'apprendre d'autres choses qui jouaient
des personnages différents et c'est en
un an plus tard donc quand j'avais 10
ans que mes frères ont commencé à
amender dans des tournois de jeux de
combat moi j'étais super heureuse parce
que je me suis dit je vais enfin me
faire des amis des amis parce que à
l'école j'étais complètement à l'écart
parce que vous notez que je disais que
je joue aux jeux vidéo
on prêtait de nolife on me disait que
j'avais pas de vie et que forcément
comme je joue alors je suis obnubilé par
mon écran je joue tout seul dans une
cave
enfin bref tout l'image que certains
d'entre vous ont peut-être peut-être
encore et j'espère ne plus mais plus la
voir après après mon disco et lorsque je
suis arrivé eh bien j'ai réalisé une
chose une chose dont je me suis jamais
rendu compte en fait parce que j'ai
grandi avec mes deux grands frères
c'est que j'étais la seule fille est la
seule enfant dans ce milieu là et ces
deux critères ont suffi pour faire en
sorte que je sois exclut encore une fois
j'avais envie de les poutres et c'est
exactement ce mot là que je me suis dit
je suis dit je vais les poutres et ses
joueurs qui me sous-estiment parce que
je suis une fille et un enfant est là en
mon for intérieur je me suis dit je me
suis fixé un but dans la vie c'était de
prouver que les femmes les filles les
enfants valent autant que les hommes
et là il a fallu des six
il a fallu décider d'un pseudonyme d'un
surnom pour participer à ces tournois et
là j'ai pensé à mes personnages féminins
que j'aime tant et dans dead or alive 2
qui est un jeu de combat il ya qu a
soumis et ayane et et donc j'ai fait la
contraction des deux prénoms et ça a
donné qu'à y aller
et donc voilà c'est resté depuis mes 10
ans le nom de kayane m'a suivi dans tous
mes tournois parce que moi qui n'avais
pas d'amis à l'époque j'avais au moins
cette force là de me dire que j'avais
cessé prénom là dans mon pseudo qui
pouvait m'aider me donner une force donc
j'ai participé à un tournoi
international où j'ai réussi à me lis et
quatrième au monde à deux ans seulement
j'ai rencontré des joueurs étrangers et
ça m'a même donné envie d'apprendre
l'anglais
j'ai aussi réussi à gagner mon premier
chèque de 1500 euros à l'âge de 12 ans
par mois qui n'avait pas de compte en
banque
je peux vous dire que c'est ma mère qui
était très contente de l'encaisser enfin
je me suis fait des amis que je voyais
tous les week-ends dans des sessions
d'entraînement en vrai un pas en ligne
ça existait à peine à l'époque et en
tournoi en fait je voulais aller autant
loire non pas pour battre d'autres
joueurs mais vraiment pour revoir mes
habits ses amis qui m'ont tant appris
quand on pense à un jeu de combat
souvent on associe cela de la violence
parce qu'il faut battre son adversaire
jusqu'à ce qu'ils n'aient plus de vie
pour gagner et là c'est des thunder de
jeu c'est des tonnes de réflexion à
avoir
on a même des petits carnets où on
entend de tout noter comme si on était
dans un cours de math et j'ai voyagé
j'ai parcouru le monde pour affronter
les meilleurs à l'image des champions de
d'arts martiaux et de sports de combat
pour découvrir d'autres styles de combat
à découvrir d'autres cultures d'autres
joueurs qui développe une façon de jouer
différente et qui est finalement super
enrichissante pour moi
et même s'il ya la barrière de la langue
il y a le langage du jeu vidéo est là
c'est super intéressant c'est ce que je
préfère dans les jeux de combat à vrai
dire maintenant que j'ai voyagé et
rencontrer plein de jour avec qui je ne
pouvais pas communiqué et bien c'est
d'avoir ce langage qu'on peut avoir
quand on joue vous savez quand vous
prenez un personnage je suis sûr que
vous avez plein de vous avez déjà joué à
des jeux de combat sans doute à street
fighter à soulcalibur au même à tekken
et vous avez toujours un joueur qui se
la joue à la cool genre un ange approche
pas j'attends tu fasses des erreurs et
ensuite j'en profite vous avez aussi
d'autres joueurs plus bourrin non ils
vont tout le temps attaqué vont aller à
fond ils vont jamais se protéger vous en
tout le temps à attaquer et à force de
faire des tournois comme ça partout au
monde
eh bien j'ai cumulé 57 podium dans des
tournois mixtes de jeu de combat 15
victoires et surtout une grosse
consécration avec le guinness world
records ce qui m'a donné le titre de
meilleur record féminin dans des
tournois mixtes de jeu de combat et je
peux vous dire qu'au début j'ai cru que
c'était une blague
comment le guinness world records ça
aurait pu nous contactez moi qui joue à
des jeux de combat mais comme quoi c'est
devenu quelque chose qu'on reconnaît
facilement de plus en plus sauf que moi
j'ai plutôt préféré suivre mon instinct
j'avais envie de vivre du jeu vidéo et
c'était une grosse prise de risques
parce que finalement c'est serré sans
les jeux vidéo et pouvoir en vivre
c'est tout aussi récent ça fait partie
des nouveaux métiers de l'air des années
2000 et mes parents il n'y croyait
absolument pas et moi je n'avais pas de
modèle sur qui m'a référé parce que en
france en tout cas j'ai fait partie des
premières qui peut vivre du jeu vidéo en
tant que joueuse professionnelle de jeu
de combat est aussi animatrice télé et
j'ai dû créer ma propre boîte il ya deux
ans mes parents me donne cinq ans avant
de terminer dans une entreprise comme il
le souhaite mais je vais continuer de
leur dire que si
vraiment vraiment vivre du jeu vidéo
mais il ya d'autres personnes qui vivent
des histoires formidables qui y met
quelque chose de personnel quelque chose
de différent quand ils jouent ils ont un
rêve un but et il ya une personne un
joueur qui m'a beaucoup touché et
auxquels je pense très souvent quand je
joue c'est boli l'egs c'est un joueur
qui est handicapé il ne peut ni utiliser
ses mains ni ses jambes et dans la vie
il dit qu'au quotidien
il est considéré comme une personne
handicapée qu'il faut aider et en fait
il a trouvé sa vocation dans street
fighter
parce que dans street fighter
il a développé une façon de jouer ou n'a
besoin ni de ses manies de ses jambes
il a juste besoin de sa bouche et on
joue chun li tous les deux et je peux
vous dire qu'il que son plaisir c'est de
faire des des coûts des combinaisons
ultra compliqué d'y arriver
ils y arrivent une belle façon où j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'a pas de handicap
mais le message qu'il fait passer en y
arrivant c'est de dire aux autres
joueurs qui n'y arrive pas
si moi j'arrive avec un handicap alors
toi aussi tu peux y arriver à force de
s'entraîner à force de s'acharner à
l'entraînement aujourd'hui
j'aspire à démocratiser davantage les
jeux vidéo à faire progresser les choses
parce que je me suis je me sens plus
vivante quand je joue j'ai découvert un
tas de personnes
une tonne de cultures différentes à
travers le jeu vidéo et jeux je souhaite
que d'autres personnes puissent vivre
autant d'expériences positives que moi à
travers le jeu vidéo
parce que je suis convaincu que c'est un
vecteur de relations sociales de
relations humaines et il y a tant de
choses qu'on peut vivre grâce à ça parce
que c'est un domaine qui est accessible
aux hommes aux femmes aux enfants aux
personnes plus âgées et vous même si
vous n'avez pas encore touché à une
manette un jeu vidéo
eh bien il serait grand temps de vous
mettre aux commandes du joueur 1
voilà merci à tous
[Applaudissements]